on l'attend dans un instant et on
voulait évidemment repartag avec vous
des extraits que vous avez certainement
vécu ici même dans TPMP puisque Julien
Courbet évidemment été été dans tes PMB
on se souvient par exemple on a retrouvé
des vidéos à vous les montrer en
attendant que Julien arrive on se
souvient quand Julien courbé était
déguisé en shy'm en Shy'm lors d'une
émission on est en 2014 et qu'il avait
fait le show
[Applaudissements]
room
bonsoir Julien Courbet merci d'être avec
nous en direct
[Musique]
mes parents on va le savoir ce qui s'est
passé Margaux qui a disparu Agnès jumeau
qui est le même s'est noyé mais les
filles ne croient pas une seconde à
l'accident et on a besoin des
téléspectateurs et je tiens à préciser
que lors de la dernière émission deux
affaires ont été résolues grâce aux
appels alors on espère que tout le monde
sera ce soir pour appeler et aider ses
familles alors question les équipes
c'est qui travaille derrière vous parce
que c'est très important il y a un
travail de recherche comment ça
fonctionne la machine
la machine vous savez elle est très
simple on a des tas de journalistes qui
vont rencontrer la police qui rencontre
des tas de gens il y a des enquêteurs on
essaie d'en savoir de de regrouper le
maximum d'informations et après
malheureusement justement on est bloqué
c'est pour ça que cette émission
intervient c'est parce qu'il y a des
affaires il faut le savoir qui vont être
classés et ça les familles elles veulent
pas longtemps vous pouvez pas entendre
quand votre enfant est mort ben madame
on va classer l'affaire parce qu'on a
rien et c'est là l'intérêt de cette
émission c'est que on peut relancer des
affaires grâce à des indices et des
coups de fil qui dès le lendemain
redéclenche une enquête question aussi
sur capital parce qu'on continue
d'animer sur sur M6 depuis 2018 vous
avez une actualité de dingue je viens
pour le cheval quand vous dormez ça
c'est ça c'est le mystère et ça vous
plaît toujours autant capital est-ce
qu'il y a des nouveautés cette saison
alors moi ce que j'adore leur capital
c'est vrai qu'en terme de d'animation
par rapport à appel à témoin ça n'a rien
à voir c'est beaucoup plus facile mais
ce qui me plaît dans Capital c'est ce
qui est raconté dedans c'est c'est
toutes ces enquêtes sur le pouvoir
d'achat du porte-monnaie je crois qu'on
est en plein dans la cible aujourd'hui
ne parle que de ça le prix de l'essence
le prix des denrées etc et capital et
c'est d'expliquer de décrypter donc des
nouveautés non de l'enquête toujours de
l'enquête de la vérité savoir ce qui se
passe derrière les étiquettes pour que
les téléspectateurs connaissent la
vérité voilà ça peut vous arriver aussi
qui cartonne alors ça on adore ce qu'on
va reprendre des extraits je vous le dis
tout de suite franchement on adore ça
depuis depuis 2001 comment vous
expliquer la longévité de l'émission
écoutez la longévité de l'émission c'est
qu'elle est tout simplement dans l'air
du temps pourquoi parce que par exemple
quand j'ai démarré il y a 24 ans puisque
l'émission à 24 ans par exemple internet
n'existait pas et maintenant on a plein
de problèmes d'internet donc au fur et à
mesure c'est c'est les arnaques qui font
qu'on est toujours dans l'air du temps
et puis parce que il y a tellement
maintenant de multiplication vous en
parlez vous-même de temps en temps
d'arnaque de problèmes etc que les gens
ont envie d'avoir des solutions et puis
là c'était du concret on résout les
problèmes et surtout surtout on en a pas
fait un show Patos c'est voilà on se
détend on s'amuse et ma plus grande
fierté c'est d'abord des gens qui
viennent sur le plateau avec un énorme
problème on arrive à les faire rire il
se moque de leur propre problème par
contre derrière il y a du concret et
puis il y a des petits coups de fil
parfois qui qui tournent un peu à la
volée de bois vert
un peu en sucette il y a votre votre
allez votre CV qui va s'afficher sur sur
l'écran vous êtes connu beaucoup de de
chaîne bien sûr vous êtes aussi un homme
de radio vous avez commencé en 85 vous
débutez à la radio donc elle
circonstance racontez-nous
les circonscients sont très simples
c'est l'époque c'est l'explosion des
radios libres moi la radio c'est ma vie
j'adore la télé attention et la radio je
l'ai dans les veines et quand tout
s'arrêtera je continuerai à aller sur
une petite radio de de quartier je
pourrais pas m'en passer c'est vraiment
ma vie voilà quand en 80 les radios
libre explosent j'ai un petit
radio-réveil parce que les jeunes n'ont
plus de radio-réveil mais nous on en
avait un j'écoutais je me suis dit un
jour faut que j'essa et j'ai eu un IUT
Tech de Co et j'avais trouvé un boulot
mais je me suis dit avant d'aller bosser
va t'amuser un peu dans une radio libre
écoutez ça a été dingue je suis allé
voir une radiologie j'aurais dit
Monsieur comment on fait pour faire de
la radio et là la personne parce que
c'était dans un immeuble 17e étage
studio Mina il me dit vous voulez
apprendre à faire de la radio libre très
bien vous commencez demain pardon mais
j'ai jamais fait ça parce qu'on a pas
d'animateur donc
demain et me voilà le lendemain qui
arrive et je vais vous raconter comment
ça s'est passé c'est couillon ne m'avez
pas dit qu'il fallait venir avec ses
disques est-ce que c'est une radiologie
et donc j'en avais pas et je dis je fais
quoi mais si t'as pas amené disque il va
falloir que tu te démerdes donc j'ai
fait la pas ma première émission était
sur deux piliers hein j'ai trouvé un
disque qui traînait par terre j'ai mis
face à face
et en disant ah les auditeurs nous
redemande à écouter cette chanson je la
remets ah ils veulent savoir ce qu'il y
a sur la face bizarre mais après il
fallait bien parler donc j'ai lancé un
concours d'histoire drôle sauf que
personne n'a appelé puisque je vous
confirme que personne n'écoutait donc
j'ai appelé ma sœur en lui disant
peux-tu raconter une histoire drôle donc
elle l'a fait elle sait pas les raconter
donc c'était une catastrophe et j'ai
fini par faire moi-même l'auditeur et je
vous jure que c'est vrai donc j'étais
qui est en ligne avec nous oui bonjour
Julien
tu veux nous raconter une histoire
et je vous assure que j'ai démarré comme
ça ah c'est génial on adore et puis vous
avez jamais arrêté depuis la radio c'est
une passion et on me dit aussi que c'est
l'heure de votre passage à énergie que
vous avez choisi le pseudonyme de Julien
Courbet j'ai appris que c'était un
pseudo moi pourquoi
je ne sais pas si vous avez cette info
j'ai été le premier animateur en France
à dire vous écoutez Fun Radio en fait
j'étais sur NRJ et un jour à Bordeaux il
y avait pas de satellite et un jour on
est venu me voir on m'a dit mais tout à
l'heure tu diras pas NRJ il est 20h tu
diras Fun Radio il est 20h pourquoi
gérer ça parce qu'on s'appelle plus
énergie maintenant ça démarre ce soir
donc c'était le premier à dire ça alors
effectivement NRJ quand j'arrive un
quart d'heure avant ils me disent on est
un petit problème ton prénom c'est
Frédéric et le type qui est avant toi
s'appelle Frédéric oui mais la raison
c'est un joli prénom oui mais on peut
pas avoir deux Frédéric sur l'antenne
j'ai dit oui mais je fais quoi moi et
ben tu t'en trouves un autre donc j'ai
pris un calendrier et j'ai essayé Roger
Courbet
[Rires]
évidemment on parle des années TF1 sans
aucun doute Julien Courbet alors ça
c'est le succès en fait c'est Gérard
Louvain qui vous repère et qui vous fait
venir à TF1 c'est ça alors je revois à
l'époque on envoyait des cassettes pour
se faire repérer j'en ai envoyé une à
Gérard Louvin il m'a fait faire un
casting et puis j'ai plus de nouvelles
et puis un jour il m'a rappelé en me
disant bon j'ai peut-être quelque chose
pour toi en fait quelque chose pour moi
c'était une chronique dans sacré soirée
donc j'ai été chroniqueur dans sacré
soirée et là aussi je vais vous raconter
une petite anecdote qui est un peu
humiliante mais vrai mais qui font le
caractère
j'attends je préviens toute ma famille
je leur dis ce soir je fais ma première
chronique dans Sacrée Soirée 10 millions
de téléspectateurs je suis au bas de
l'escalier derrière les gradins
Jean-Pierre renard en train d'allumer
Julien Clerc le machin et compagnie et
maintenant je commence à monter les
marches nous marquons une pause il ne
m'a jamais appelé
vous imaginez j'avais prévenu mais la
France entière bon après je l'ai fait
une ou deux fois c'était pas terrible
jusqu'au jour il y a eu un petit
magazine qui s'appelait pourquoi pas
vous j'en ai fait trois et puis est
arrivé sans aucun doute 16 ou 17 ans
extraordinaire mais très prenant parce
que un sans aucun doute ça prenait 7
heures d'enregistrement donc j'étais à
la
finesse
je peux vous dire que
j'avais des chaussettes de contention et
je prenais des tisanes jambes lourdes
mais au bout d'un moment voilà j'ai dit
il faut que je me calme un peu j'avais
eu j'avais envie un peu de
divertissement et c'est comme ça que je
suis parti sur France 2 ça se passait
super bien sur TF1 je peux même vous
dire qu'il m'avait proposé un contrat
mais mirifique à l'époque et je l'ai pas
accepté parce que je voulais faire du
divertissement j'étais sur France 2 ça
n'a pas marché vous le dis tout de suite
le passage sur France 2 c'est soldé par
un petit fiasco mais au moins j'étais
jusqu'au bout ça c'est valable vous avez
vous êtes enrichi d'autres d'autres
talents et d'autres de d'autres
expériences bon allez quand même les
années TPMP
mais mes meilleurs souvenirs je vais
vous dire c'est quand Cyril me donnait
l'animation du vendredi et l'animation
du vendredi on l'enregistrait en fait le
jeudi soir alors le jeudi soir il y
avait le direct animé par Cyril après il
fallait marquer une pause obligatoire
pour les les horaires des techniciens et
on reprenait je crois à 22h30 sauf que
entre le direct et le moment où on
prenait à 22h30 on allait à la pizzeria
et à la pizzeria il servait du rosé
que une ou deux fois on a fait les
émissions d'ailleurs c'était même plus
ça c'est pas les mêmes pas de médias ça
nous faisait que ricaner pour rien ce
n'est pas quelqu'un disait quelque chose
ça a été une période ça finissait minuit
et il y a eu des périodes je vous assure
on était à la limite de tomber de la
chaise mais ça a été une période
extraordinaire où je me suis éclaté et
j'ai ça m'a conforté dans dans le fait
de pouvoir faire aussi à la fois
peut-être du magazine mais aussi du
divertissement et c'est pour ça je
remercie Cyril alors Julie on a un petit
extrait vous allez voir de vous à
l'antenne avec un certain Cyril Hanouna
dans l'oreillette voilà ce que ça donne
quelqu'un vient de prendre mon
oreillette en otage et ils savent
et il est en train de me donner des
consignes
[Rires]
regardez
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut lui mettre un peu de
son qu'on en profite tous parce que
c'est un personnage exceptionnel qu'il
était en train de me faire
je t'aime bien Julien
mais je préfère
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
c'est sur sans aucun doute où il avait
demandé l'autorisation d'utiliser le
plateau pendant une pause pour faire un
DVD où il faisait des sketches et moi je
l'avais jamais vraiment rencontré avant
et je vois donc il me demande de jouer
mon rôle donc je l'avais interviewé il
faisait le témoin qui c'était plus qui
lui avait une bêtise pas possible et
c'est comme ça que qu'on s'est rencontré
et je dois le redire que quand moi ça
s'est mal passé après sur le service
public il a été le premier à m'appeler
ça j'ai la mémoire et je n'oublierai
jamais
tout est prêt là on voit que tout est
prêt le plateau est là vous avez pas
pouvoir rester non plus jusqu'à 2h du
matin
ça s'agit d'un peu mais
j'en suis certain me met en valeur c'est
une évidence voilà nouvelle extrait
[Musique]
des Landes de pierre
autour des blagues c'est pour les
vivants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous faites bien de le dire suite à
cette épilation en tout cas je sais pas
il y en a eu plusieurs épilations mais
il y en a une ça n'a jamais repoussé
donc j'ai on va faire je vous assure ici
là vous voyez il m'a épilé ça n'a il m'a
dit t'inquiète pas ça repoussera ça n'a
jamais repoussé j'ai des jambes de
danseuses sur la plage à cause de ça
on fait passer le message on fait passer
le message merci infiniment en tout cas
merci on c'est un bonheur de vous avoir
appelé moi ce soir évidemment avec
Julien Courbet ses équipes voilà il
compte sur vous évidemment vous comptez
sur les téléspectateurs pour résoudre
ces affaires merci Julien et à très
bientôt c'est un plaisir